la lettre que bernard cazeneuve a
adressé hier à tous les policiers n'a
pas suffi à calmer leur colère
il ya un zéro pointé pratiquant ce
truc-là ligne sur la façon dont le
gouvernement gère cette crise là et plus
largement dans président de la
république se comporte depuis un certain
nombre de mois maintenant par ce qui me
choque ce sont les attaques que
subissent les policiers et les gendarmes
avec une violence qu'on avait jamais
connu jusqu'à présent parce qu'il ya
même des tentatives d'homicide contre
les forces de l'ordre
il faut redonner du tonus aux
socialistes leur redonner du moral delà
de la fierté défendent ce que nous avons
engagées c'est à dire le bilan même si
évidemment il ya des réussites et
également des échecs rien ceux qui
considèrent le prémice comme un
collaborateur ceux qui considèrent le pr
venisse comme un concurrent ce qui n'est
pas un moindre projet vu par exemple
mais par exemple vous voyez bien triste
demande arnaud à benoît
aurélie emmanuel patois l'autre qu'est
ce qui nous sépare son appel au
rassemblement il devrait nous amener à
revoir aujourd'hui ce que sont nos
échecs sortir de ce déni le quinquennat
de françois hollande est pour partie
l'accélération plus à donner manuel
valls est largement aujourd'hui
responsable de la situation dans
laquelle se trouvent les français
nous devons donc réagir réagir vite
réagir pour cesser de subir réagir
maintenant pour ne pas mourir demain car
à la présidentielle vous imaginez que
vous allez affronter qui françois
hollande ou manuel valls ségolène royal
et manuel
sur l'éventuelle embauche affrontera le
candidat que la gauche choisit pourquoi
pas vous non non parce que j'ai laissé
mon temps parce que j'ai déjà beaucoup
donné
le moment n'est pas venu d'aborder la
question de l'échéance présidentielle
mais vous en parler ce qui se passe chez
les socialistes cette semaine c'est
terrible non mais quelle question soit
l'élu soit légitime changement
disconvient pas elle a fermé la porte
n'a pas fermé
elle ouvrait rêve aurait été d'être élue
députée européenne en 2009 avec dany
cohn-bendit et de le voir dans
l'hémicycle c'était ça dont j'avais
remis par petit matin à 7h de longues
files d'attentes se sont formées dans le
calme près des centres d'enregistrement
des migrants ça devient folie nous avons
10 millions de pauvres 6 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pays et ont déjà des
ghettos communautaires des ghettos de
zones de non droit et on nous demande
d'ajouter encore des migrations fait
tout ça cela ça n'a aucun sens que je
vais tout mettre à l'abri l'ensemble des
personnes qui se trouvaient encore
aujourd'hui sur le campement et dont la
grande majorité a fui les guerres des
persécutions
le cac repart lentement il sera géo
localiser en permanence par cette petite
boîte placée à côté du chauffeur des
bâches en plastique autour des sièges
revoyez les images j'ai 100 n'ose même
pas imaginer la raison pourquoi cette
entreprise de bus a pris la décision de
bâcher les sièges de ces bus au nahd
dans notre monde des bombes de menaces
de déplacements de populations qui sont
immenses revoyez les déplacements de
population dans le monde sont sans
précédent et actuellement 50 millions de
personnes 50 millions qui ont dû
s'enfuir de chez elles par combien coûte
un taux chocolat jean françois copé fait
ça dépend des cas et je pense que ça
doit être un loto de 10 ou 15 centimes
d'euros par litre de lait combien ça
coûte et des ponts vous l'achetez entre
0,60 centimes d'euro et un euro sans
contrat dépend
ces 100 g de chouquettes je l'aimais off
aller j'émettrais au-delà de 1 1 euro en
dessous de 2 et au delà d'eux en dessous
de 2 c difficile à trouver fait perdre
l'élection de 2012 françois d'ailleurs
je suis un citoyen j'ai le droit de
voter pour qui je veux comme ring pour
héroux que je connais bien été quatre
fois candidat à la présidentielle le
prix n'a jamais passé fait des choses
aux gens qu'il dirige à l'udf non sens
peut pas dire qu'on ait fait des choses
ensemble il a été ministre est question
nationale aérien touché en cinq ans il
épate
on doit les avoir autour de 80 entre 90
centimes et un euro il pas quelques
liquides je vais souvent dimanche matin
dans la boulangerie vient d'être chez
moi j'achète un croissant un pain au
chocolat pendant une chocolatine est une
ficelle jamais pour 3 euros parc c'est
là qu'on voit qu'il est urbain ce
citadin parce que chez moi dans la
sarthe on parle pas de ficelle qui me
plaisait quand je dis chiche ou que tu
chemin de l'école c'était la boulangère
d'un chocolat un nouveau tremplin
messieurs de break
je crains d'avoir été un peu mort ou de
la boulangère qui était assis corpulente
j'avais à l'époque à l'école primaire
et cette histoire de pains au chocolat
ça lui colle comme un sparadrap je pense
on a dit que vous étiez prêts à suivre
macron c'est vrai ou pas dans ce faux
c'est faux c'est fou en plus je ne
suivrai pas presse que ça fragilise pas
une candidature qu'on commence à fleurir
les plans b pour seul et les plomber les
plans c'est les plans h du nom de
quelqu'un d'autre on les prend ton temps
mon gars tu arrêtes ministre deux ans tu
l'on passait là encore on passe pas de
la casquette de j'ai jamais fait de
politique je viens de rothschild et là
je couds à part peut-être que toute
cette gauche pourraient s'unir deviner
derrière derrière qui derrière
christiane taubira on en parle de plus
en plus je ne crois pas que christiane
taubira qui a déjà été candidate à
l'élection présidentielle puisse demain
puisque c'est la question que je me pose
être élue présidente de la république la
baisse sur un mois est historique 66300
chômeurs de mois en catégorie à
c'est à dire sans aucune activité un
chiffre immédiatement salué par françois
hollande qui parle d'une tendance
installée depuis le début de l'année
notre politique économique porte ses
fruits
le chômage baisse avec 90 mille
demandeurs d'emploi de moins depuis
janvier il faut poursuivre ce soir on a
des résultats qui confiant le fait qu'il
ya une inversion de la courbe du chômage
qui est engagée qui est constaté en 2003
soit en 18 millions en tout ont quitté
hier le bidonville ont été transférés
vers des centaines de centres d'accueil
répartis un peu partout sur le
territoire
nous avons renoncé à avoir une véritable
politique de reconduite à la frontière
des migrants illégaux il faut reprendre
cette politique il faudra lui donner
aussi une dimension européenne alors
qu'il négocie son entrée au gouvernement
avec nicolas sarkozy
voici ce qu'il aurait prononcées je ne
veux pas de l'intérieur je n'aime pas
les flics pas la justice
je déteste les juges prison des propos
d'il ya plusieurs années que j'ai pu
tenir sur certains points d'autres sont
déformés ou tronquées et en tout cas je
n'ai pas pu dire ça parce que je m'en
passe pas un mot par 4% le chiffre c'est
le dernier sondage pour vous pour la
primaire en même temps un certain
françois hollande avait démarré à 3% à
la primaire de la gauche il est
d'accéder à l'elysée
3 j'espère faire mieux je foutais 4 %
des français sont satisfaits de l'action
de françois hollande selon le dernier
baromètre du cevipof
le chiffre du oui il ya une inversion de
la courbe du chômage dans la d2 2016 et
françois hollande est en train de
relever le défi de la bataille de
l'emploi créé là dessus on peut
applaudir françois fille françois fillon
nom françois hollande
on applaudira françois fillon parce que
françois fillon c'est celui qui nous
permettra de retrouver la croissance
oui un milliard d'euros je vous dirais
que ça nous a coûté à nous les
contribuables parce que la réalité c'est
françois hollande à acheter la baisse du
chômage américains nar estime que cette
baisse du chômage a été obtenue en plus
artificiellement
beaucoup de chômeurs serait envoyé en
stage afin d'être sortis des
statistiques par françois mitterrand
l'ancien président aurait tué
aujourd'hui 100 ans
un hommage lui a été rendu
fram et du louvre françois mitterrand un
opposant qui n'a jamais cédé au moindre
découragement même quand les épreuves
semblait l'avoir écarté à tout jamais de
la vie politique
le risque c'est que nous soyons sap et
de la présidentielle on a un problème
d'incarnation certains de ses amis
proches lui dit c'est dangereux d'y
aller il ne faut pas se faire humilier
est ce que vous voulez donner un homme
sur la cei un homme françois mitterrand
qui n'a cessé de rassembler rassembler
la gauche pour ensuite unir le pays
car quand vous entendez le patron du ps
jean-christophe cambadélis il était à
votre place il ya deux jours dira si
c'est pas hollande ça pourrait être
valls n'est qu'en dites vous manuel
valls
mais tout cela je longtemps oui et donc
emmanuel macron toujours pas candidate
dit son attachement à la fonction
présidentielle
pas forcément au chef de l'état voir il
doit tenir compte de la situation
il doit donner un sens à ce que pourrait
être sa candidature et un nouveau
quinquennat
cette décision lui appartient de
fonctions qu on occupe à un moment donné
elle nous dépasse et donc moi mon
souhait à tous égards c'est qu'on a
faits puissent pas la fonction
présidentielle rien à cette phrase qu'on
sort souvent de mitterrand je serai le
dernier des grands présidents
entraînements il y aura que des
comptables la véraison
écoute je peux il l'a dit dans
l'hypothèse où alain juppé candidat les
républicains françois hollande n'arrive
que cinquième derrière le possible
candidat emmanuel matheron et derrière
jean-luc mélenchon il avait raison il a
des bon allez c'est un petit tout petit
peu de votre réserve il a raison non
mais il l'a dit
pour les copines pour rigoler oui faut
du sang neuf
et puis en même temps vous faire barrage
à nicolas sarkozy donc on va voter pour
alain juppé qui est un vote par défaut
et je dis à tous ces électeurs un vote
par défaut
ça donnera la même déception que
françois hollande parce que justement on
le trouvait trop froid trop ennuyeux
mais vous dis justement c'est l'époque
qui a changé parce qu'on a envie de
s'ennuyer avec à l'enjeu une vraie
déclaration d'amour
lorsque le chef de l'état prend la
parole pour le centenaire de la
naissance de françois mitterrand toute
la gauche gouvernementale est présente
voir ici je dois sifflé la récréation de
10 minutes du match c'est le
rassemblement
leur à ce moment parce qu'il n'y aura
qu'à ce candidat les anciens ministre
les actuelles
les représentants de la majorité mais il
ya un grand absent
quand on est dans la vie politique
depuis longtemps de ne pas supporter
d'avoir à l'épiderme fragile un
président de l'assemblée ne va pas faire
simple claude bartolone ici au perchoir
plus tôt dans la journée s'est bien
rendu aux commémorations
avant de quitter la salle quand françois
hollande a pris la parole parce que je
reproche à ceux qui aujourd'hui à partir
d'un livre
s'énerve c'est dommage qu'il soit pas
énervé au moment de la loi travail
interrogé sur une possible nomination de
claude bartolone à matignon le chef de
l'état a exclu catégoriquement
il n'a pas l'envergure il n'est pas très
connu le jour il le deviendrait il n'a
pas un charisme considérable qui l'a vu
qu'une petite enquête qui vient de
sortir très particulière 4% s'est encore
pas mal mais lui voulait rassembler au
débat bah oui il a rassemblé
l'opposition et l'opposition contre lui
qu'on me paie le maquereau du petit
journal jeune luca fait bon vicieux
écoutez je prends ça comme un hommage
et si ça peut vous porter chance ont su
ravir ils sont amusés à regarder quelle
était la cote de popularité du président
de la république six mois avant
l'élection suivante vous auriez quelques
conseils à me porter vos cousines vous
déjà pour françois hollande évidemment
c'est une sorte d'ascensions de
l'everest vous voyez il est tout en bas
de la côte à gauche en compagnie de
nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs vouloir
persister paraître président de la
république alors qu'ils sont rejetés
l'un comme l'autre
effectivement il ya une part de
masochisme ou alors de déconnexion avec
la réalité
alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy se sont
donné rendez vous à marseille pour un
duel à distance n'est pas coupable
d'avoir voulu faire partager sa culture
aux peuples d'afrique d'asie et
d'amérique du nord
c'est ce que vous voteriez françois
hollande contre le front national
si la situation se présentait par ses
propos la rentrer dans une longue
tradition de propos racistes que
tiennent les dirigeants pour les flics
français à l'égard de l'afrique et de
nous moi je n'ai jamais voté pour le
front national je n'ai pas l'intention
de le faire non voteriez pour françois
hollande
pas de gaieté de coeur c'est la vendée
par l'émoi dans la jupe et
longue tradition le propos racistes
voulait de moi s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi filmer ou s'il vous plaît je
me suis dit qu'à l'écran et c'est ce
qu'il est sincère ce monsieur bourdin ou
pas quand il me veut et puis tous les
matins que vous voyez je me dis pas tous
les matins mais c'est le matin s'il vous
plaît pas il faut que je récompense tant
d'insistance pour me voir j'ai pensé
figurez vous je vous manqué sa part ça
m'a demandé d'intervenir et qu'en fin de
compte monsieur fillon il parle plus que
moi